as you guys know i love gossip i love my
tea isn't that true sona yeah you you
love your hot god i call it tea
isn't that uh something that i should be
i don't think you can say i love my tea
i don't know if that's the way it works
and it sounds weird coming from also
often when i say it i just like an
actual tea
chamomile i think that's what you mean
yeah i don't mean yeah conan this
segment's supposed to be about gossip
okay
well my enthusiasm level just dropped
incredibly because i have all these
facts at my disposal about different
blends
uh your english breakfast your scottish
lunch
did you you researched tea before this
segment thinking we were going to talk i
take these segments seriously and i went
to the library because that's the only
place to get information and i i went
through the library cards the dewey
decimal system but now that i know that
it's about gossip i'm even more excited
because i love gossip i love and as and
as you say sona i loves my hot goss so
i'm very happy to report that team coco
finally has
a gossip expert in the house comedian
solomon giorgio very happy that he's on
board yes hi hello
that's solomon laughing there solomon uh
i love anyone who just giggles at their
own name that is your actual song
every time i hear i'm like are you sure
yeah yeah trust me my name my first name
gets a laugh out of me every time
but anyway solomon has been in the team
coco family for a while he's appeared at
our live shows he's been on the late
night show and uh just before the world
went on lockdown solomon uh hit send on
a tweet that changed his life the tweet
was i don't care about celebrity gossip
give me small scale gossip and you had
no idea what you were going to get back
when you sent that tweet out did you no
i did not i did not expect hundreds of
responses to
truly the most just an afterthought that
i had just in the middle of the day yeah
the tweet went viral complete strangers
started sending solomon their juiciest
stories now he's serving them up on the
juice a brand new podcast from team coco
featuring solomon and a celebrity guest
discussing low stakes gossip stories
uh it's low stakes and very high on the
petty yes that's i think which is i
always like petty gossip i love uh good
petty i've held every grudge my entire
life
single has been let go
the irish all we're really known for is
very green grass and the ability to hold
a grudge
for thousands of years over the smallest
things oh you put the stone on my side
of the farm it should stay on your side
of the farm
and then they they're bitter about it
for a thousand years uh anyway solomon
thanks for being with us and you've
brought some juicy uh gossip to share i
want to hear this because i want to
weigh in i'm a very wise man well this
actually i brought um
some historical gossip some some stuff
from the past because gossip has been
around for a while it's been like
segments and newspapers for the longest
time gossips gossip's been around it's
been around for a while i think right
after adam and eve were kicked out of
you know eden the gossip started yeah
about
this naked man and woman and what was
with a snake and how come the apple and
so yes it's been with us since day one
and it's probably kept the earth turning
so conan matt i know that you both are
history buffs uh so these are historical
pieces of gossip that uh that we put
together for you these historical uh
pieces of gossip come from the hamilton
evening journal august 6 1892. um
yeah this is juicy a woman not a
thousand miles from richmond was without
doubt
the most flurried female in seven
counties when she discovered after
coming out of church sunday that her
brand new hat was adorned with a tag
whereupon was inscribed the legend
reduced to 275. oh god so how
humiliating for her yeah she bought a
hat on she's absolutely she bought a hat
on sale and was probably humiliated
because it made the paper right it made
the paper but also like she's leaving
church she's supposed to not people
she's supposed to have the newest hat
i'm assuming because it's a church
function yeah the sunday finals she
showed up
and she didn't she didn't take the tag
off also this this just shows you how
little was happening in the news that
day
or
or what a bad newspaper it was because
what if this was the same day that like
president garfield was shot and they
were like what should we do the
president's been shot in a train station
in washington wait a minute this just
over the transom
stop the
presses the president
he'll either live or die there's nothing
we can do about it
but well look you know in you know enid
crabtree just wore a reduced hat
at the methodist church
we've got to get this out there do you
remember minnie pearl she used to wear a
hat with the tag hanging down is this in
reference to that
it can't be no no no no this was a very
i don't think minnie pearl knew about
this story she might have sometimes
like look she might be all knowing she
might be the woman
that would make minnie pearl who i i'm
gonna gas passed away like 10 years ago
so she would have been um i don't know
120 when she died i'm sorry could happen
a rapper that just hit huge just out of
nowhere
you got to know what's going on
right straight out of straight out of
oakland uh no minnie pearl oh
yeah minnie pearl was famous uh was at
the grand old opry she was a comedian
and then she was on hee haw she was uh
you know big time uh comic
in her day and that was her trademark
was a tag hanging from her hat so those
are things i love that you're learning
sona about the history of women in
comedy
yes from from you a man in comedy it
makes sense sort of in comedy i guess i
don't know
but yeah it's unclear to me what i'm
doing anymore it is just the reduced
price hat is sort of the thing that's
like you can't it is gauche you can't be
caught in that situation so many pros
doing like a nice little tip to
uh something that's happened to many
women unfortunately of course nowadays
to get to elicit the same kind of
scandal you'd probably just have to walk
naked do you know what i mean uh out of
a church that you just set on fire to
get the same amount of attention this
society has changed so much i don't
think if someone saw a a reduced sale
tag also that would look cool like i
think aren't there a lot of celebrities
who like to let it out there that i only
spent eight dollars on this or i only
spent this was only 15
and and you're seen as thrifty which is
which is cool and there is a fashion to
keep the stickers on your ball cap for a
long time too but also like it shows
like how different our society was
people like talk about canceled culture
like she got cancelled for wearing a
reduced-priced hat
we hoped she was just canceled she may
have been run out of town
or murdered
who knows we don't know this the stakes
were very high back in the 1890s and so
we don't know what happened to her i
think it's just safe to assume
uh that she was
just
dismembered
maybe she was gonna return the hat after
church so she left the tag on and a lot
of influencers do that now or they buy
expensive clothes keep the tags on and
then return it after they take photos
for you know their social media i feel
like that's i think i think back in the
past all sales were final i think that's
usually okay also uh she was also
responsible for the first selfie as she
came out of the church
she waited
she waited while a guy with a camera
she waited with a guy with a camera set
up the tripod uh put the flash powder on
the pan
um put his head underneath that big
sheet and then set the daguerreotype
levels to this correct uh settings and
she had to stand still for 40 minutes
for her selfie
wait that's not a selfie she had to get
on yeah she got under the curtain she
got under the curtain she got everything
just right then she lit the fat the
flash powder and jumped back into frame
uh and it was it was the first recorded
selfie uh august 6th 1892 look it up
solomon what else you got the city of
humboldt in kansas has a young woman's
military band that goes around playing
for picnics and celebrations it may be
all right for a woman to play on a brass
horn but it makes the lips hard just the
same what
oh what year are we talking about here
this isn't 1892 same this is also
happening in 1892. yes women were just
going insane at this time
[Laughter]
so like she'd walk around town and
everybody be like oh there's hard-lipped
sheila over there don't go near yeah
there was a whole it was actually a
whole woman's band military band on top
that so they were in the military so
wait a minute wow uh
i'm confused the it does make the lips
hard was considered a bad thing yeah
that's the part that i'm like i feel
like is it just because they're all
women and they shouldn't be getting
their lips hard and that's against the
rules i think so i don't understand i
don't know but it sounds
kind of sexual yeah wow
oh i think it's that their lips have
been spoiled they don't have soft lips
anymore oh okay i was saying the way it
was written sounded sexual yeah i like a
hard-lipped woman
what about like chapped crusty lips like
that i like that too that sounds great
you know oh yeah honestly
smooth lips really they just they don't
tell a story and that's what i think the
issue is
yeah i think that's i'm with solomon on
this one anyone can have smooth lips
that just means you you haven't lived
life
but give me a hard-lipped woman whose
lips are chapped crusty flaking
uh i want you want her to leave some of
her lips yes exactly yes i want it to
feel like what i wanted to feel like i
just kissed
a a freshly sandblasted banister and and
that's what i like
hey that's what i swear to god first
thing when i saw my wife way back in
2000 across the room first thing i shot
it was yo you got some hard lips
and then i said kim i said give me some
of that skin chap
oh god yeah i said flake me up baby
anyway she refused oh no yeah i had it
took me a year to recover just from that
she got a restraining order uh but then
about a year later she had forgotten
that i said that i said that that was
someone else and she believed it so we
got we got past it i'll ask her this is
good gossip i like this i like
historical gossip this is good i like my
i i like uh
i call it the goo give me the goo don't
i always say that sona who yeah
what's the goo and to me that just means
the gooey sweet gossip the goo that's
what i like
my favorite memory uh i used to work at
the jcpenney uh the suit department and
i would just go hang out with women in
the perfume department and they would
smoke menthols and then we'd watch
passions and the entire time we would
just swap stories of gossip so that's
like that's always going to be that
sounds amazing you watched passions i
loved it i watched it too oh my god that
was the best it was so it was a fever
dream opera i was just gonna say it was
a fever drink i didn't see this soap
opera made it so great it had witches
and a like it had a living doll
it was very very wild yeah living doll a
little person played a living doll and
it was all shot on early video
i remember that i didn't watch it but i
remembered everybody was talking about
it it was insane it was off its rocker
crazy bring back passions that's all i
came here for that's all yeah you know
what i want to do i want i want to uh
let's see if we can't uh use our
resources uh solomon and get some
behind-the-scenes gossip from the making
of the show passions i bet we can get
something good going there i'm sure i
can't i probably i probably can't do
that uh i'm gonna actually doing them
right now after this yeah yeah
i can't i can't think of a better use of
uh two adult uh time than to
drop everything we're two adults
all right well
what are you gonna do
uh this has been it's been a lot of fun
um and i i'm very happy that you're
you're getting to do what you love
that's the trick in life solomon find
out what you love
and then trick people into paying you to
do it and uh congratulations sir just a
reminder everybody from workplace
romances at denny's to moms with secret
lovers oh my god each week solomon's
source is only the best everyday gossip
from comedians performers and listeners
like you in fact uh i went on the juice
i had a blast sona i think you did as
well right i did i had so much fun i
really did talk to solomon was awesome
well he's here listening of course
you're going to say that yeah allegedly
yeah i know yeah um and he's i was
paying him a compliment yeah but you're
on zoom and i saw you do air quotes and
he was awesome
so insulting so insulting do you think
he said i hope i know i don't think so i
saw him i was he's crying now he's
visibly crying so uh do with that what
you will but probably crying about
something else yeah uh but anyway uh no
it really is fun new episodes of the
juice are out every week listen wherever
you get your podcast and thank you
solomon thank you so much